so yesterday we talked about these very
very unusual and and sort of seemingly
pointless in some way retweets by the
president Donald Trump of some
anti-muslim videos he retweeted three
absolutely insane videos supposedly of
Muslims committing different acts of
violence from an extreme right groups
member in the UK the group is called
Britain first and the tweets were from
Jada Frandsen now of the three videos
yesterday I already told you we knew
that one of the three was fake in the
sense that it was not actually what it
claimed to be it was not a video of a
Muslim attacking anyone
it was a non-immigrant non-muslim Dutch
guy but that didn't really matter right
the the main point was this is
understandably concerning behavior why
is an American president retweeting this
stuff and it apparently was as as
concerning to British Prime Minister
Theresa May as it was to many of us she
criticized Donald Trump for those
retweets may said after Trump did this
retweeting that Trump was wrong to have
retweeted the videos not hugely
controversial but still it is the prime
minister of a foreign Ally that is
saying the president did not do the
right thing
what did Trump do he took to Twitter he
took to Twitter as he often does
initially tagging a different Teresa may
who has only six followers on Twitter
and then in normal Donald Trump fashion
eventually taking that tweet down in his
endless comedy of errors and tweeting
the actual British prime minister where
he said Theresa May don't focus on me
focus on the destructive radical Islamic
terrorism that is taking place within
the United Kingdom we are doing just
fine and as I read this I found myself
asking is this the real life or is it
just fantasy because the idea of Donald
Trump telling others not to focus on him
that's hilarious right given that all
Trump wants other people to do is to
focus on him and only in the world of
the low information Trump astiz this
type of behavior from a president
something we could even imagine
remotely pleased with many trumpets
actually support Trump not despite this
type of stuff going on Twitter and
criticizing the leader of a foreign ally
but because of it they hear this and
they say hey listen Trump does politics
differently and that's a good thing we
should all be glad that Donald Trump is
not like the other politicians you can
make that case but explain specifically
how the retweeting of the Muslim hate
videos and the slamming of leaders have
allied conflict countries via Twitter
accomplishes any political objective I
would actually want to hear from a trump
is to say hey here's why we should be
glad that Trump retweeted those videos
and then slammed Theresa May on Twitter
this is one of the USA's closest allies
they are understandably increasingly
skeptical of sharing information with us
after Trump opened his mouth to Russians
about information shared by Israel in
the Oval Office information from another
ally and then now Trump takes to Twitter
to attack the Prime Minister and it's
mostly sad because even if Trump is like
it we all suffer from Trump making the
US and international embarrassment when
Trump damages our relationship with the
UK or with Israel or whoever right the
Trump is might like it because for them
it's Trump being the strong man who's
not going to be pushed around the
progressives don't like it but everybody
is impacted by it if the UK says this
guy is unhinged we're not going to share
information with the US anymore it's not
gonna make a difference whether you
voted for Trump or Hillary or whoever
it's bad for you yeah you have to know
how to pick your battles too I mean he
shouldn't have retweeted these posts to
begin with sure but then after that let
Teresa may say her piece I mean they are
after all our top Ally
they're both right-wingers - it's all
just very surprising and maybe once he
found out that he had retweeted the
wrong person then lied well now at now I
thought that I got it
yeah III agree with you I don't think he
can hold back I think that the pick your
battles pick your battles implies that
there's some critical thinking going on
where Trump is actually evaluating like
okay let me think is this worth tweeting
about or is it not maybe I should save
some of my Twitter
capital or whatever for some something
else I don't think that's going on I
think the guy can't control himself
and anytime anyone says anything he
takes to Twitter and nobody in that Oval
Office or around the president can can
get him get him not to do it this entire
thing is making me more convinced than
ever that what we know of as the
universe is actually a computer
simulation and you and iPad have been
randomly assigned to the madman in the
White House test scenario I know that
the it's actually a hypothesis that many
astrophysicist scientists of different
kinds have talked about are we could we
be living in a simulation if we are I've
definitely gotten the short end of the
stick in terms of which simulation I'm
in I wish I was selected for something
else yeah III would like to be in the
Bernie Sanders wins and we figure out
what happens if you actually have a
Democratic Socialist as president of the
United States
that's the simulation I'd like to be
chosen for the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership